if you argue that big data requires all
of the three v's
volume velocity and variety it wants to
count as big data proper
then is it possible to be a data
scientist if a person with domain
expertise and statistical knowledge and
encoding skills without touching big
data
we'll look at a few of these
possibilities
first let's review our venn diagram of
data science
this again shows on the top right we
have statistics on the bottom we have
domain knowledge and on the top we have
coding
taken together those class to data
science
we also have a venn diagram for big data
where we have volume
and velocity and variety and again
depending on who you ask
you need to have all three of them at
once to a big data
so let's take a look at data science for
just one v at a time
so we're talking about statistics and
domain knowledge and encoding
but with just velocity or variety or
volume
the first example we want to look at is
volume of data without any remarkable
velocity or variety
so this would mean a very large and
static data set with a consistent format
the data would generally be structured
as well so we're not going to have free
text
a good example of this is genetics data
as i'm showing right here from nature
reviews
genetics data is huge it's enormous but
it follows a well understood structure
and now there's an enormous amount that
you have to do to work through it
but it's consistent in that way
next is data science for velocity
without volume or variety
so this is referring primarily to
streaming data with a consistent
structure by streaming data we mean the
data is coming in consistently and very
often you're not holding on to the data
you're just keeping a small window of it
open
one interesting example is the
earthquake detection systems of the
united states geological survey
this is the advanced national seismic
system which is simply looking to see
whether there are earthquakes that are
happening or really about to happen
and you don't necessarily need to hold
on to all the data if what you're trying
to do is trigger a response so that if
an earthquake is imminent
or if it's just starting people may have
enough time to respond to it
another term for this kind of data where
it's coming in very fast
but you're not necessarily keeping it so
it's relatively low
in volume and it may have a very
consistent structure so it's low on
variety
this can also be called data stream
mining
and one possible example is what's
called real-time classification of
string and sensor data
finally for one v at a time let's talk
about data science for a data that has
variety
so a lot of different formats without
velocity or volume
this is where you have a complex but
small or static or relatively static
data set
a couple of examples could include
facial recognition and personal photo
collection
so you don't have an enormous number of
photos but you do have a lot of variety
visual data is almost
always very high in variety and it may
be static because you don't add to it
constantly
or you can talk about the data
visualization of complex data sets
now these are examples of data science
which again means statistics
and it can mean domain expertise and it
can mean coding
or you're doing just one of the v's of
data at a time
you can also do two v's at a time so for
instance you may talk about data science
for data where you have volume and
velocity
but not a lot of variety so for instance
a lot of data is coming in very fast but
it's in the same format
you can include for instance stock
market data
here is another example it has to do
with jet engines
and a surprising statistic here comes
from this chart
it is estimated that a jet engine has
sensors on it that generate 20 terabytes
of information each hour
that's an enormous amount of information
for instance
20 terabytes per engine per hour times
two engines
times six hours cross-country flight
times 28
000 flights and 365 days a year
the total data generated is over 2.5
billion terabytes of data per year just
from jet engines alone
the point here is it's a lot of data and
you would want to hold on to that
because the failure of a jet engine
is an extraordinarily important thing
and so you want to be able to find the
patterns in it fully
another possibility is data science
applied to data that has velocity
so it's coming in fast and there's a lot
of variety but not a lot of volume
so again this is streaming data where
you're not necessarily holding on to
everything
one interesting example of this is
surveillance video
if you're saving all the data then
that's an enormous volume
on the other hand if you're not saving
it but you're streaming it in
it's very fast because the information
comes in very quickly
maybe 20 30 frames per second and it has
a lot of variety
because it's visual information but if
you're simply wanting to see does a
person come through for
instance who's carrying a weapon or does
a particular event occur
you use a stream and you're just trying
to trigger when something happens
finally let's talk about data science
for volume and variety without velocity
and this can be any large historical
data set that uses multiple formats
or includes visual data a really good
example of this is google books
we've looked at this before where they
have 30 million books that they've
scanned and they've digitized them
and you're dealing with a really complex
information here
similar examples include the twitter
archives where every single tweet that's
ever been written has been saved
that's an enormous amount of information
because its text is complex
but because it's not updated constantly
it doesn't have the velocity
what these examples show is that despite
the strong association between big data
and data science
the skills of data science the
statistical knowledge and domain
expertise or knowledge in coding skills
those apply even when the three major
aspects of big data aren't all present
at the same time
in the next presentation we'll look at
the flip side of all this
how to work with big data without
requiring the full data science skill
set
you